do the cast give you a hard time about
this no
she's fierce and powerful but she can
also be very clumsy as cool as she looks
on screen elizabeth olsen was often
experiencing total embarrassment on set
for everything from her costumes to
awkward slip ups to accidents while
filming we've got the scoop on all the
times the scarlet witch lost her cool
number one sets can be a serious
workplace hazard elizabeth olsen was in
a surprising amount of danger for
someone who was just walking although it
was pretty intense walking i
fell on my knee so hard
because i was trying to walk down like
rubble
aggressively part of the issue was that
you can't look at the ground when you're
trying to be scary being unable to see
with such unstable ground beneath her
was tough enough throw in all her
scarlet witch angst and fury and you've
got a bit of a clumsy avenger on set
olson was left seriously hurting by the
end of the shoot both knees covered in
bruises
number two rewind play rewind play we
could watch this all day long
next up we've got one of the best scenes
in marvel history the epic women of
marvel in action however olson wound up
getting a lot more attention than she'd
bargained for and definitely more than
she'd hoped for in this instance it was
another clumsy moment for the scarlet
witch and this one involved another
person i landed in the scene on wires
and i lost my balance and i fell
backwards and got totally slammed in the
back of the head by those dumpers and it
was running luckily olson wasn't
seriously injured and as unfortunate as
the incident was the scene captured on
film was a hilarious one and the messy
moment was watched back by the cast and
crew over and over and over again not
only that they went full slow motion
with it to really get the best effect
number three who knew kisses could lead
to so much anger paul bettany and
elizabeth olsen are a match made in
heaven
paul and i have worked with each other
for now six years and have never been in
a legitimate argument it wasn't until
snot gate that the two really clashed it
wasn't a cute situation but it certainly
didn't feel like something to get so
upset over while he was painted purple
and kissing me his snot had dripped onto
my face and he got so genuinely angry
and defensive
olson was shocked and completely
embarrassed on set feeling very
uncomfortable at the fact that her
co-star was truly angry with her
especially over something seemingly so
small we got over it quickly but it was
definitely a weird a weird moment
fortunately these two still have nothing
but love for each other
number four cgi magic really makes a
difference when it comes to the scarlet
witch's powers there are few images in
the mcu as powerful as wanda maximoff's
intense explosions of magic but behind
the scenes she doesn't exactly look so
epic she's at a rave the whole movie
yeah
while it looks abstract being captured
on camera and left olson self-conscious
at her wild actions there is indeed a
method to her madness we start off with
like a center energy kind of thing olson
actually had a choreographer build
wanda's physical language with her
giving her the ability to really tell a
story through movement without any cgi
magic present and you want to move it
around but without the added vfx yeah it
does look kind of hilarious
number five how far is too far exactly
elizabeth olsen and paul bettany found
out the hard way the actors were pushing
the limits of how far they lean into the
comedy with a lot of support from their
director matt shakman in the pursuit
considering how wacky they got the
actors figured they'd never end up going
too far that is until olsen crossed a
line there are moments where i'm i'm
dealing with coats and i did like a
triple take instead of a double take
shackman's take he wasn't into it he was
like let's stick to the double take the
triple take was too much they had made
it to filming the third episode before
getting shut down which was impressive
and olsen took it in stride i felt like
there's a badge of honor to finally get
my
that's too much
number six it's wanda live in front of a
studio audience
just hearing that could get olsen
jittering with nerves totally new to
performing in this odd hybrid style the
actress has done theater before but
filming the old-fashioned way with
cameras and eyes witnessing everything
she was doing it was a bit too
overwhelming i feel like i was really
nervous before with the sitcom because
it was our first time filming this show
and it was in front of an audience the
pressure was immense and olson worried
about what would happen if the audience
didn't care for the show or if something
went wrong while filming we're just like
filming our failure if you know if it
were going to fail was going to fail in
front of a bunch of people fortunately
wandavision was anything but a failure
number seven it's classic but it sure is
different olson is a total pro when it
comes to filming work that will
eventually have cgi done but tackling
the old-fashioned cg style was a very
foreign experience
there were a lot more actual strings
behind the scenes than there would
normally be and of course an audience
there to witness it all olsen handled an
embarrassing moment incredibly well when
she realized she had to stop performing
mid scene in front of an audience in
order to let the practical effects team
do their work
and then i change
[Music]
the actress has never really had to
explain what she was going to do next to
everyone watching number eight sometimes
it's the smallest things that can get us
we're throwing it way back to captain
america civil war the pressure is on
when it comes to filming such a major
motion picture but olson was really
struggling to keep a straight face long
enough for the cameras to get everything
they needed i hear people laughing
vision ducking out of the scene was just
too funny for olson to handle and to be
fair it does look pretty hilarious we'd
be giggling too
number nine
she's gotta feel fierce to be fierce in
one division we get to see all sorts of
variations on her costume including the
fabulous new scarlet witch suit however
before that the actress was always
wearing her red corset olson didn't mind
the fact that it was a corset at all but
what did bother her was the fact that it
revealed so much cleavage something her
fellow female avengers didn't have to
deal with the actress has expressed her
embarrassment around it explaining i'm
the only one who has cleavage and that's
a constant joke because they haven't
really evolved my superhero costume that
much fortunately the new scarlet witch
suit gives her all the power and flair
and much better coverage
number 10 even the slightest smile can
ruin a take but olsen's smirks weren't
even that subtle at times as we've seen
before olson has a tough time keeping a
straight face around her co-star in part
because the two get along so well paul
was trying to do his vision thing but
olson couldn't for the life of her keep
it together and wound up ruining take
after take being the one responsible for
having to refilm scenes so many times
leads to some very embarrassing feelings
on set number 11 maybe it was a bit too
close wanda and vision were inseparable
so evidently olsen and betany had to get
very close with each other and it was
just a bit too awkward for olson to
handle sometimes which left the team
with a whole lot of takes full of
laughter they may have had embarrassing
times but it didn't mean they weren't
still plenty of fun
number 12. name a more iconic duo get
aaron taylor johnson and elizabeth olsen
in a room together and it's going to be
a good time though it did lead to some
embarrassing bloopers for olson
so bad but the blooper footage it's so
good and there is no denying that
number 13. she managed to avoid it for
quite a while i think the sad thing is
wearing that costume without any irony
when olson was first joining the mcu
joss whedon assured her one thing you
will
never ever have to wear what she wears
in the comics and that remained true
that is until one division the actress
was embarrassed to have to don the suit
she had explicitly been told she
wouldn't have to worry about but she was
a good sport about it especially because
she didn't have to go through it alone
for paul to be dressed in his it was
so
fun number 14 who knew a bat could even
bend that way
whether or not olsen was on wires she
somehow achieved freakishly wild
postures ones that bring on a whole lot
of embarrassment when looking back at it
i guess i do that a lot don't i number
15.
offset could be even more embarrassing
than on i was just looking at him like
you look so weird with your skin
olson has spent way more time with
vision paul bettany than she has with
the real paul bettany it was weirder to
see him as paul bettany than it was to
see him in purple seeing him in the
flesh well things got awkward any time
he like didn't have his makeup on i like
would get a little uncomfortable like i
didn't know this man it just goes to
show that not everything is as it seems
and no matter how cool someone looks on
screen they have their fair share of
awkward moments too which situation did
you think was most embarrassing